this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream get free access to
nebula the new streaming platform built
by and for creators when you sign up for
curiosity stream at the link below I
[Music]
wonder if you could tell me how
expensive you think calling an ambulance
out it's your location is in America
okay is there a price for now yes two
and a half grand why they build our
insurance company over three million
dollars for the cost of transplant I
don't know what people do without
insurance how how could you even begin
to pay that she said the bill is up to
eighty thousand dollars already and she
said mrs. Wycoff I hope you realize that
you're responsible for this bill I
thought what am I gonna do I've worked
my whole life is this how my life is
going to end in a previous episode I
briefly touched on the failures of the
American healthcare system that section
of the video prompted all sorts of
responses in the comments mostly from
Europeans who were horrified to learn
that Americans have to pay for an
ambulance ride to the hospital but also
a handful of brave Patriots who claim
without evidence that the American
healthcare system is the best in the
world this video is for those people
let's jump right in I'm gonna throw a
bunch of statistics at you and then
we'll look at the root cause of the
problem America spends more money per
capita on health care than any other
nation on earth
you would think that this expenditure
would guarantee the best care in the
world that is not the case in fact
despite being the most expensive health
care system on earth consuming over 16
percent of our GDP it's one of if not
the least effective in the developed
world we spend over ten thousand dollars
per capita on health care and not only
is the quality of care subpar we don't
even cover everybody
compare this to places like Germany who
paid drastically less per capita and
guarantee coverage to all their citizens
there were over 27 million uninsured
Americans in 2018 and that number will
have skyrocketed in recent months thanks
to the millions of layoffs across the
country even before the epidemic we had
more uninsured and underinsured citizens
than any other developed nation in
addition to not covering a large portion
of the population even those with
excellent by Americans day
health insurance struggle to pay medical
bills over 25% of insured people
reported having difficulty paying for
the exorbitant cost of their treatment
of this group
63% had to pay most or all of their
savings to cover the medical bills and
42% had to get a second job life-saving
drugs in America often cost 10 times
what they cost in other countries for
example in Canada one vial of insulin
cost $32 in the United States the same
drug from the same factory cost three
hundred dollars and that's not even an
extreme example take the HIV drug
Truvada in australia it costs just eight
dollars in the United States it costs
$2,000
despite US taxpayers footing the bill
for its development every year over half
a million people go bankrupt trying to
pay their medical bills in a country
where 40% of the population can't afford
a surprise $400 expense an ambulance
ride to the hospital will cost you more
than twice that amount and all of this
is happening in the richest country on
earth if we have the resources and we're
so much better than all the other
countries why is our health care system
so broken here's the thing it's not
broken it's functioning exactly as you'd
expect it to America's health care
system is for-profit that means instead
of providing care because it's the
ethical thing to do they only do it
because there's a big check involved
back in the 30s Blue Cross and Blue
Shield were the two main health
insurance providers in the u.s. in those
days they operated as nonprofits and
wouldn't turn anyone away for any reason
then after World War two employers
started offering health insurance as a
benefit and between 1940 and 1955 the
percentage of insured Americans jump
from 10% to over 60% this new demand for
health insurance caught the eye of many
business people and the for-profit
health care industry was born by 1951
big names like Aetna and Cigna were
major players in the industry which
continued to grow through the 70s and
80s in the 80s the country began to see
its first for-profit hospitals operated
by large investors who owned multi
Hospital chains by 1981 one in seven
hospitals in the US was for-profit
suddenly medical bills became a lot
longer and more convoluted every little
thing became an itemized expense from
tissues to plastic cups to being able to
hold your baby after it's born the
hospital's transitioned from
philanthropy to corporation was complete
this is not normal in other countries
America had taken the intensely cruel
step of taking something sacred the
health and well-being of its citizens
and slapping a price tag on it with this
commodification of health came
unsurprising side-effects average
American life expectancy is lower than
other wealthy countries and has actually
begun to decrease in recent years
compared to other countries slowly
increasing the US has the highest infant
and maternal mortality rates of any
developed country
the US has higher rates of medical
errors than other countries adults in
most other comparable countries have
quicker access to a doctor or nurse when
they need care
contrary to what American health care
advocates would have you believe to make
a long story short in just about every
study on the effectiveness of health
care systems and developed nations
America scores very poorly most of the
time at the very bottom of the list and
other nations are taking notice towards
the beginning of the corona virus
epidemic one University in Norway urged
its students to come home if they were
studying in countries with poorly
developed health systems such as the
u.s. part of the problem is the American
obsession with streamlining or
optimization anything that doesn't
immediately increase profits has to go
take for example the practice of
so-called just-in-time delivery of
essential equipment such as ventilators
instead of having an emergency stockpile
including personal protective equipment
such as masks and gloves these items are
instead delivered only when the need
arises the idea is to reduce overhead
but in reality it leaves us totally
unprepared and under-equipped for a
national pandemic that's why we see
pictures of doctors and nurses wearing
trash bags because their hospitals
haven't provided adequate protective
equipment and just to be safe they're
firing people who post those kinds of
pictures to their credit the CDC was
planning to address the national
shortage of ventilators but the company
to whom they had given the contract was
bought out by a larger company who
canceled the project because it wasn't
going to be profitable enough and of
course that larger company's name is
Covidien because the architects clearly
put an intern in charge of our
simulation I could spend all day listing
off instances of absurdly high medical
bills but at the end of the day some
people in America will still defend the
practice of for-profit health care maybe
the best way to get through to these
people isn't to show them the bills but
to show them what people in other saner
countries think of the bills so here you
go I mean let's call out how much things
your payment zero payment yes zero
payment no because two and a half
thousand dollars for real inhaler
a hundred dollars one hundred twenty two
hundred fifty to three hundred fifty for
inhaler so two EpiPens
how much do you reckon they are $80 600
$600 dollars the average is about 10
grand it can go to 30000 10 grand for a
baby it's okay to laugh it's a funny
video but these are the types of
reaction you get when you explain to
anyone in a first world country besides
the u.s. just how screwed up our
healthcare system is we're not paying
these exorbitant fees for quality care
we're paying for executive bonuses
shareholder value and lucrative
contracts pharmaceutical and medical
device companies can charge whatever
they want and the US government will
never step in we're one of the only
nations on earth that doesn't regulate
the cost of drugs and medical supplies
and companies negotiate directly with
hospitals and insurers to get the best
terms not best for the patient best for
them drug costs in America are many
times higher than in any other country
why because that's how it works in a
for-profit system the dollar holds
infinitely more value to these
corporations than human well-being the
needs of the people are secondary to the
profit motive the American healthcare
system is a system that relies on people
getting sick and coming in for treatment
which is why we don't see any investment
in public health initiatives a program
like Medicare for all would likely solve
this and every other health problem
produced by the corona virus pandemic
everyone would have been able to see a
doctor and get tested which would have
given us more accurate data about the
illness and its spread hospitals
wouldn't have to waste energy dealing
with private insurers and fighting them
on every little thing and with the
profit motive removed from the health
care equation the government would have
an incentive to prioritize public health
to prevent people from getting sick
instead of counting on it that in turn
would make us better prepared for the
next pandemic
but remember the system that we have
isn't broken
it's functioning exactly as it's meant
to why do we pay so much money for the
worst care in the developed world
and more importantly why do we put up
with it if you'd like to learn more
about the virus that made it clear just
how ill-prepared the US was for a
pandemic I highly recommend you check
out the corona virus epidemic on
curiosity stream it's a fascinating look
at how the world responds to a rapidly
spreading virus and the measures we can
take to stem the tide of infection if
you watch my videos you'll know I'm a
big fan of curiosity stream it's an
online streaming service with thousands
of nonfiction titles from some of the
best filmmakers in the game you can find
tons of great episodes like the corona
virus epidemic and they've got a bunch
of material on technology and outer
space which are some of my favorites
they're giant catalogue includes content
on science nature astronomy technology
and lifestyle among others unlimited
access starts at just $2.99 a month and
as a special offer just for you guys you
can get a free trial by following the
link below
curiosity stream is available on just
about every platform you can imagine so
wherever you are you'll always have
access to great interesting content as
an added bonus
your curiosity stream subscription now
comes with a free Nebula subscription
nebula is a new streaming platform built
by and for creators like Wendover
productions real engineering Kurtz
Kazakh and of course second thought and
many others it's a place for us to try
new things and make original content
that just wouldn't be possible on
YouTube give curiosity stream a shot and
get free access to nebula when you visit
curiosity stream comm slash second
thought if you enjoyed this video and
would like to see more like it consider
subscribing to stay up to date with my
latest episodes if you hated it go ahead
and drop a thumbs down and if you really
want to help support my channel I
recently started a patreon which you can
find at patreon.com slash second thought
you can watch my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen thanks
for watching and I'll see you next week